- [Gary] Everybody's got shit
and nobody cares
about your shit,
they care about their shit
'cause everybody's got shit.
So, nobody cares about
your fuckin' complaining,
go fuckin' do
something and that's it!
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I been telling you.
- When you talk to an
upcoming entrepreneur and, say,
they wanna build their brand,
how do they effectively
break through the overwhelming
amount of information
and distortion
that exists out there?
- Talent and effort, that's it.
There's just nothing else.
By the way, there's
nothing else in anything.
How do I become a
professional hockey player?
Talent and effort.
How do I become a
tremendous, top 1% lawyer?
Talent and effort.
How do I become a
phenomenal mother?
Talent and effort.
It's talent and effort
and what I love about effort
and why I love hustle and, now
that's it's become so cliche,
you see me saying the word
"work" a little bit more now
'cause I just want people to
get it, it's controllable.
You know, like,
it's controllable.
Like, you know, it's
controllable and I'm obsessed
with it because
the other part's not.
Like, I wasn't
born six-foot-seven
and can run like a cheetah.
I mean, that's
just the punchline.
You've got to ... It's a game
of poker, you get a hand.
Nobody's gonna cry
for you about your hand,
nobody's gonna say,
"Oh, it's terrible
that you're not fast or tall
"or gorgeous or
talent... Or can sing."
It is what it is and now the
only thing that can happen
is you can figure
out how to navigate it.
Many have won in poker
with not the best hand,
and that's how I think about it,
and so I was given
the things I was given
and I'm trying to maximize them
and that's why I talk a
lot about self-awareness.
I could wish I was something
or I can realize I am something
and try to maximize
on that and that's,
I think what I've
done extremely well
and why I preach it immensely,
'cause it's quite practical,
is I deployed
enormous amounts of humility
and self-awareness and
said, "This is what I am.
"I'm not gonna play for the
Jets but maybe I can own them,"
and I honed those
skills, and that's the key.
- Thank you, brother.
- You're welcome.
- Appreciate the words--
- Men up!
- Man, let's do it!
Thank you, my friend.
- Could we take
one shot with Gary?
- [Man] Yes, of course.
- For the social,
we'll push to keep.
- [Man] For the 20-year-old
advice, what I took from it
is that you've
gotta do the hustle
and the 60-year-old advice
was it's not too late.
So, we're in the middle
there, what would you tell us?
- Both.
- Shit, what?
- It's not too late, clearly--
- Okay.
- And you've gotta work your
ass off, and you've gotta,
like, you know what's crazy?
Is when I give patience
advice to 20-year-olds it,
you know, they've got their
whole life in front of them
but it's hard
because they wanna prove
and they're
impatient, da da da da.
When I give a 40-year-old
patience advice,
which is the
answer I'm giving you.
- Yes, I'm breathing, listening.
- It's not as fun
'cause you're like,
"Wait a minute,
though, like, you know,
"I've already been through
a couple of chapters, like,
"I don't wanna be patient.
I've been patient."
You know, and by the
way, what did you say
I gave the advice to
60-year-olds?
"It's not too late?"
- Yeah.
Guess what that means, patience.
Like, the
fundamental thing is this:
Nothing good has ever
been built from scratch
without hard work
and patience, nothing.
And I don't, you know,
I think people are confused
about a Snapchat or an
Instagram or a Facebook
or a child star or
an NBA athlete at 18.
Yes, .0001% of us
have this miraculous event
that creates
all-time life impact
and income impact
in a very short period of time.
But for the
99.999% of the rest of us
there is one formula:
Hard work, patience,
talent in that arena.
And then your outcome is the mix
of how good you were
at those three things.
- [Man] Yep.
- [Gary] So, you know,
that's it, I mean,
like, what else is there?
Like, show me, show
me the other formula.
Show me the quick spam,
show me the eight-week
course that did it for you.
Like, show me,
show me the examples.
It's actually called strategy.
Here's the finish line,
I actually mean it.
Like, I actually mean
that's the finish line.
Like, that's actually
what I want to happen
and I'm gonna do my behaviors
every single day of my life
because this is
actually what I want.
- [DRock] How'd your day going?
- Good.
Good morning but then I got a
little bit of stomach thing,
which felt weird.
- [Man 2] What's goin' on, man?
- Hey, man, good to see ya.
- Nice to see you, too.
- How ya been?
- How ya holdin' up?
- [Gary] Holdin' in.
- Yeah?
- Hangin' in.
- Hangin' in?
I like the PureWow.
- [Gary] Yes, let's do it.
- You feelin' okay?
- Alright.
- [Gary] Yeah, my stomach
was botherin' me but I'm,
I think I'm gonna make it.
- [Man 2] You must be used
to all of this now, hey?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Man 2] Just a lot of runnin'
around and interviews.
- [Gary] It's become real life.
Hello, everyone, hello.
I think you have to
execute against your truth.
People can smell things.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- [Gary] You know, I was there
early on with TOMS Shoes
and met Blake and,
like, he actually meant it.
Like, he actually went there.
He's an entrepreneur,
he's a hustler,
but he actually felt
like he wanted to do that.
But then every single
entrepreneur in 2013 and '14
pitching me, "Gary, I
wanna change the world,
"so here's how I'm gonna do it.
"I'm gonna raise a ton of money.
"I'm gonna build a business I'm
gonna make a ton of money on
"but I'm gonna give a
granola bar to every single kid
"every time
somebody buys a granola bar,
"which I doubled the price of
"so I can still keep my margin."
- [Man 2] Yeah. (laughs)
- Like, this is my favorite.
I'm a businessman,
I love it when people are like,
"Gary, I'm starting
a granola bar company,
"but really I'm also one of
these new-age millennials
"and I give a
crap about the world."
- [Man 2] Right.
- I'm like,
"Okay, keep
going, Pat," and he goes,
"Yeah, so here's my theory,
"I'm gonna sell this
granola bar, it's delicious.
"I got the best chef
ever, this granola bar
"and I gonna then
donate a granola bar
"to the kids in Africa
'cause they're hungry."
"Okay, Pat, keep going."
"Now," da, da, da, da.
Then I'm like, "Pat, I'm
looking at your business.
"Why is your granola
bar twice the price
"of every granola bar?
"Oh, I know why, Pat.
"Because you
wanna keep all the money
"from the first granola bar
"and the only way you can
give the other granola bar
"is if you double the price
and subsidize your donation.
"You're full of shit, Pat."
Pat lost.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- I've seen a million Pats lose.
When it comes from
a true place you win
and when it doesn't, ya don't.
- [Man 2] I love it.
- And by the way,
are there one or two
Pats a generation that sneak
through the system and
scam it all the way through?
Of course, but do you wanna
be Pat laying on your yacht
in the Caribbean,
one out of a trillion,
the other trillion are looked
as assholes, fuck-faces,
not respected, bad humans.
But one Pat out of a trillion,
do you actually wanna
lay there and sleep at night
and realize what
kind of dude you are?
Chick you are?
'Cause I use Pat
'cause you could be both.
(Man 2 laughs)
So, you know, I mean,
that's just a stupid game.
99.9999% percent of
you are gonna be deemed
as not good, one in a
gadrillion gets through
and you still gotta
sleep at night, stupid.
- [Man 2] Yeah,
I agree, I agree, man.
Well, it's an
honor to have you here.
- Thank you, man.
- [Man 2] Thank you so much.
- Thanks for having me.
- [Man 2] And lookin'
forward to you crushin' it.
- Cool.
- Thank you, cut.
- It was nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Guys,
thank you so much.
You guys aren't comin' out?
- Ah, we will.
- We'll be out filmin'
you on the field--
- [Gary] Hi, you're welcome,
nice to meet you.
- Thanks very much.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- That was awesome--
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- Super honest.
(Gary laughs)
- You know what, that the
best. That's why it works.
- [Man 3] Totally.
- That's why I love doin'
Q&amp;A, like, people don't do Q&amp;A
'cause they
don't know their shit.
- Right?
(group laughter)
- And they're
scared of questions.
I'm not scared of any
question, like, ask it.
- Right
- Like, what people
don't understand is
it's unfortunate that,
I only, like, I stay in
a very narrow lane
but I love when
somebody asks me a question
and I say, "I don't know."
You wanna really build
trust, say, "I don't know."
Especially 'cause I have so
much bravado in what I,
in my world I really know,
so then when I get
to say, "I don't ..."
That's why Q&amp;A's so great.
Either I crush it or
I say, "I don't know,"
which are both wins.
Honest is the game, man.
- It's game time!
- A legend,
- He's going out.
- So, what you
were doing, actually,
was your intent was to
look like a good person,
but still make as much money,
every dollar
that you would have,
if you didn't
have the bullshit model
that you were
donating something.
And, so what you were were
completely full of fucking shit!
(audience applause)
- So, if you wanna
actually accomplish
the thesis of this conference,
you need to make it sure
that your intent is pure.
Your intent.
The way you make your money,
The way you make your money
is something you're proud of
Don't be full of shit
'cause you're tricking
the 90% that don't matter
and you're losing equity
with the 10% that do.
Number two: do.
You've gotta work.
You feel super
inspired from this weekend?
You can't wait?
What happens next Thursday?
What happens next month?
You have to actually work a lot.
You know zero people.
Zero
people that have
built something big
that haven't put in a
ridiculous amount of work.
And the bigger it is,
the more they worked.
So many of you have your mouth
way ahead of your actions.
Really?
You're gonna own an island
and you fucking go to Coachella?
Fuck you!
(audience laughter)
You know how many people here
want to be a millionaire?
Do you know how rare that is?
Have you run the math?
You have this enormous audacity.
You have this enormous audacity,
yet you're not putting
in the work to get you there
because you think,
somehow, you've been tricked
by yourself or somebody else
that there's some system.
That's there's
some fucking shortcut.
There's not fucking shortcut.
You've gotta put in the work.
Lots of it!
And that comes at the expense of
golfing all the time.
going to every goddamn event.
And it definitely
comes at the expense
of watching one
more motivational video,
and three more books,
and seven more p--
You have to do.
The way to win
is as old as time.
Do the right thing
and put in the fucking work.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
Speed wins everything.
Speed is absolutely
one of my two or
three religions in business.
Speed. Fast.
Everybody's too precious.
You're overthinking
your content.
your decisions.
You're better off doing 16 times
and being right 3 times
than not doing anything at all.
You're pondering.
You lack the confidence
because you're
worried about what people say.
I like losing.
That's why this is all so easy.
I don't give a
fuck if you said I lost.
I--
(audience yell)
-t's true!
It's an important thing, bro!
- [Man 4] Fuck, yeah!
- I love your beard.
- [Man 4] Thanks!
- You're welcome.
(audience laughter)
But beard dude there is
reacting to the right thing.
(laughter) And
I'll tell you why.
By not worrying about
what other people think,
it allows you to do things.
By doing things, you either win
or you learn from your loss
and it creates speed.
It's the
absolute mental difference
between the people
that are executing winning
versus the people that aren't.
It's the fear of others.
I don't want to lose,
but I'm
definitely more disappointed
than your opinion
and your blog post
about my loss.
- [Man 4] Preach!
(laughing)
- Go, go!
- I got to help you off.
- Alright, fine.
These people got
to go! (chuckles)
- Thank you!
- Give him a round applause!
Stand up, stand up!
- [Gary] Thank you!
- [Man 2] Stand up!
(audience applause)
- [Gary] Thank you!
- [Crowd] Gary, Gary, Gary!
- [Woman] If you don't mind...
- Grab your selfies.
- [Woman] Gary,
will you sign this?
- God, these selfies!
Holy smokes!
- [Woman] Thank you!
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- [Woman 2] Gary,
what's your favorite city?
- Hold on, hold on!
- [Gary] Vancouver! (chuckles)
- Before, like, sheer chaos--
- (chuckles) New York City.
- ensues. Before sheer chaos
- [Man 6] Say hi for me, Gary!
- [Man 2] You guys in
the front are classy people.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Man 2] Boom, there we go!
You'll have time, don't worry!
Can I give you these?
He's going to be outside,
he's going to be outside!
- [Man 6] Excuse me, a question!
Hey, I'm an
immigrant just like you
and my mission in life is,
how do you help a
100,000 immigrants
not suffer the
first two generations
by doing minimum wage jobs?
How do you
accelerate that stop time?
- [Gary] You can only
teach people how to fish.
- [Man 2] Alright, let's go!
Pull him away, pull him away!
- [Gary] Fuck it, let's go.
- [Woman 2] Oh, they're
gonna lose their mind now.
- [Woman 3] Oh my God.
- [Woman 4] Gary,
this is unreal.
Thank you so much.
- [Gary] You're welcome so much.
Thanks for coming.
- [Woman 5] Wow. (laughs)
- (mumbling) so nerve-racking.
- Nice to meet you.
Thank you.
- You're for real.
- [Woman 4] You're not
just behind the camera.
- I'm not just behind the video.
- I just like seriously.
- The same, and we're
gonna like each other,
but that's
against the human will.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, what are you gonna do?
How are you gonna--
- Not force the unwilling
but force the
ones that are capable,
because there's
hard-working immigrants
stuck doing the wrong jobs.
- No, sure.
So just start it.
You have to understand, the
unwilling come to the market.
You don't need permission
from anybody to do it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You can't sit
and dwell and say,
do you know how many companies
wanna market to
12 to 18-year-olds?
A shit load.
You just need to go ask every
one of them to give you money.
- Got it.
- When I started VaynerMedia,
nobody wanted to do
social media marketing.
And I had a big name
and I had a million
followers on Twitter
and I built a big business.
I had street cred, and
"No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
"no, no, no, no, no.
"Yes," but for a
number that I hated,
but I had to take it.
I had to take it for
$5,000 a month from (censored).
These are big companies,
and they wanna pay
me less than they do for
the stupidest shit on Earth,
but I had to take it.
It doesn't matter what you want.
It matters what they want.
You just need
to not dwell on it,
and just ask everybody.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- You also talk about the brand,
because I have to
really jive with--
- I don't even have enough time
for my employees and family,
so that's why I want
to be fair and say no,
but I'm giving away
my time in my community.
That's how I'm doing it.
So whether it's 60 Second Club
or randomly just
asking in an email,
it could happen.
Especially in
today's environment,
where so many
people living their,
it's way better for you
to take the seven people
that you wanna be like or admire
and watch what they're
doing than read their book.
It's way smarter to watch
what I do every single day
than it is to
read my book, you know?
We're so lucky.
We get to watch
people's actions in public.
It's so powerful.
- [Man 7] Yeah, it's true.
- There's a reason
I wanted you guys
on my Instagram story today
to hit the
notification bell on YouTube.
You should
understand what that means.
Why did I do that?
Why do I care that?
Way more than
me talking about it
14 months from now of why I did.
Pressuring everybody
don't listen to what I'm
saying, watch what I'm doing.
Watch what I'm doing.
Watch what I'm doing, you know?
And so, what do you
think you're gonna do?
There's unlimited
motivational speakers.
- [Woman 5] Right, right,
it has to do with--
- [Gary] I'm not a
motivational speaker.
I'm gonna say it
every single time.
I understand
I come off that way,
but it's what I'm doing
that's so much more important.
- Yeah, you're a businessman.
- [Gary] There's a lot of
motivational speakers
that are in the
business to just make money
off people that
don't want to do.
They're bottom-feeding.
I don't want anybody
that doesn't want to do.
Notice how I'm saying things
that nobody says like
"Don't watch my content."
They all want you
to watch their content,
so you can buy their course.
- Uh-huh, yeah.
- What do you
think is happening?
What's the matter with you guys?
- Mhmmm.
- [Gary] So I dont' know, what
do you think you're gonna do
for your friends
that wanna come to you?
If they're just your friends.
If you have a
business that you want
to sell to them
to motivate them,
well, that's a different story.
- That could be something that
could turn out into as well--
- I'm gonna tell
you something right now.
It is the worst
business in the world.
- Mhmmm.
- Selling to unmotivated people,
because you're bottom-feeding.
- Okay.
- [Gary] That's why I don't do it.
I give the right answers,
and then I hope you
do something about it,
but that's not
where I'm making my money.
I'm not making my money on you.
- [Woman 5] Mhmmm.
- [Gary] Everybody else
is making their money on you.
I'm not.
I don't like that business.
People are selling
to the bottom 10%.
- Mhmmm.
That's where they
make all their money.
The people that will never do,
and will continue
to buy every course,
'cause they think some
new person came along--
- Change your life.
- And they
unlocked it, you know?
That they figured it out.
- [Woman 5] Okay.
- [Gary] I will never sell to
somebody who's not fixable.
- [Woman] For sure,
yeah, just happy to--
- [Man 8] Hey.
- You're welcome, bro.
- [Man 8] I just wanna
say you are a legend.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- [Man 8] Say something
to my Snapchat, please.
- [Gary] Yes, stop bullshitting.
You're all fucking full of shit.
(group laughter)
- [Woman 6] Gary.
- Yes, I'm listening.
- [Woman 6] Okay, I just wanted
to say thank you in person
for answering my
family business question.
- You're welcome.
- [Woman 6] It meant
the world to me.
Can I just get a quick picture?
- Yes.
- [Man 9] You talk a lot
about self-awareness.
How do you get your team to
be on that same level as you?
- By giving them
everything they need.
You work for your team.
- [Man 9] Yeah, absolutely.
- They don't work for you.
How many people
are in your team?
- [Man 9] Right now 15.
We're trying to get to 25.
- Great, how many
times have you sat down
with the 15 one by
one for three hours,
and asked them what do
they care about in life
and how do you help them?
- [Man 9] Got it.
Yeah, that's important,
yeah, I get that.
- That's the answer, bro.
How do you get
your team to care?
Care for them first.
- [Man 9] I get that.
- You know?
You're worried about 15 to 25
without getting 15,
giving them everything you got.
The reason Vayner got so big
is those first 50,
I gave them everything.
At 800, it's harder.
- [Man 9] Yeah.
- So you need those
50 you gave so much to
to pick up the pieces.
Got it?
- [Man 9] Yes, sir.
- Your 15 to 25, 25 to 80,
is gonna be irrelevant
if you don't make
these 15 feel like
they fucking
mean the world to you,
and you actually do for them
what matters to
them at your own peril.
You should leave.
- [Man 10] Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Dude, you're so fucking young.
Learn something else.
- No, but we
built the whole thing.
I built it for him, but he
won't give me a partnership--
- [Gary] So you
need to fuck him.
You need to leave.
You're in a bad spot.
You're in the same spot
I was with Wine Library.
- [Woman] I can't push back.
- [Man 10] Man, I've been
making this decision forever.
Like a year now.
- Dude, it's the worst,
but I'm telling you right now.
The quicker you move
and let the poison out,
and start forgiving.
Otherwise you're
gonna be stuck forever.
Where are you going?
- Well, I got
three kids and shit.
I can't have that--
- Well, that's right,
but then you've gotta,
you have to
understand, it's binary.
That's what's so crazy about
these hard life decisions.
There's no half-pregnant, right?
Either you're stuck,
just because that
happened in the beginning
and you thought
it would work out.
So many of those
things have gone wrong for me,
I can't even--
- [Man 10] But
it's the family biz.
- I get it, man.
So if your brother has control,
you've got a problem.
- [Man 10] Well,
my dad started it.
He had to sell it,
or give it to him.
- Okay.
- Because the government--
- [Man 10] And then,
now he's the boss,
which he should be the
boss of a way bigger company.
- Okay.
- [Man 10] Me and
my dad work awesome.
- Understood.
- [Man 10] But he's
a fucking douche.
- Okay.
- [Man 10] Just walk away, or?
I want to still sell my shit.
- Okay.
- [Man 10] Because I'm
the only one in the world
that knows it the best.
- Well, that's a good start.
If you got the--
- [Man 10] I'm the
face of the company.
- Well, you're in a great spot.
So what do you sell?
- [Man 10] Air conditioning.
- Great, can you--
- [Man 10] For growers.
- Great.
Do you have a non-compete?
- No.
- Sounds like you
could start a business.
My problems seem
far less silly now.
I got problems.
I don't want to
be here on a Saturday
when my family's not here.
- [Woman 7] Right.
- [Gary] I got problems,
but guess what?
I made my bed,
I'm making my choices.
I got my reality.
- [Woman 7] That's right.
- [Gary] Every single
person here has shit.
All of you, you all have shit.
Do the white
dudes have it better?
Yes, guess what,
they still have shit.
Everybody's got shit,
and nobody
cares about your shit.
They care about their shit,
'cause everybody's got shit.
So nobody cares about
your fucking complaining.
Go fucking do
something, and that's it.
Go Google conferences and email
that you'll speak for free.
- [Woman 7] Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
- [Gary] That's it.
- [Woman 7] Got it.
- What, you think
somebody's gonna along
and be like
"Oh, we're so sorry."
- No.
- "Here, we'll
put you on stage."
They don't care.
- I'm here for a reason.
- [Gary] You got it, that's it.
All right.
(group applause)
Real quick, where is it?
- [Woman 8] Good
luck on draft day, Gary.
- Thank you.
Alright, guys, I gotta go.
- [Man 11] Thanks, Gary.
- You got it, brother.
- [Man 11] I appreciate
what you did.
- [Woman 9] Thanks, Gary.
- [Gary] Thanks guys, love you.
See ya.
- [Man 12] Hey.
- Ah, you missed it.
- [Woman 10] You gotta go.
- Awesome.
- [Gary] Got it, awesome.
- [Woman 11] So what
would you like to do?
Do you wanna go back to
your hotel for a little bit?
- [Gary] Yes,
that would be amazing.
Thank you, Vancouver.
That was good.
Lot of fun, felt really nice.
It's really the
manifestation of all my words.
You know why you
haven't had to deal with that?
Nobody's giving.
Everybody's
taking, and that's it.
When you give, you win.
Thank You Economy and
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook
were written back to back
in the middle of
my storm for a reason.
Pay attention to the cadence
of how I write my books, DRock.
Okay?
- [DRock] Alright.
- [Woman 11] You're
openin' up now.
(shouts)
- [Man 12] Yo,
what's up man?
- [Gary] Yo man.
- [Man 12] We knew we
were gonna find you.
- [Gary] Let's do it.
- [Shane] Shane.
- [Gary] Shane,
nice to meet you guys.
- [Man 12] So, my one
question I never got to ask--
- [Gary] Real quick 'cause
I have to catch my family.
So I have to really go.
Go ahead.
- [Man 12] When the intent,
the more you grow, the more--
- [Woman 12] I love you so much!
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Woman 12] So much, Gary!
- [Gary] What's that?
- [Man 12] The more you grow,
the more your
intent gets challenged,
what do you do to prevent that?
- [Gary] Okay, never
waver from your intent.
- [Woman 12] It didn't take.
- [Man 12] No matter what?
- [Gary] No matter what.
(camera clicks)
- [Man 13] There we go.
- [Woman 12] Sorry.
- [Gary] No worries.
Nice meeting you.
- [Woman 12] You're amazing.
- [Man 13] Nice to
meet you, Gary.
- [Man 14] Can you
grab one for me?
- [Man 13] Yeah.
- [Man 13] Thanks, pal.
- [Woman 12] Sorry DRock.
I saw you and then I (laughs)
- [Gary] Cool.
- [Man 13] Thanks so much.
Hey thank you Gary.
- [Gary] I'm okay, lets do it.
- [Man 13] DRock,
I respect what you do man.
You're the dream.
- [Man 14] Auto, auto, auto.
- [Man 15] Gary,
with me and my wife--
- [Gary] Let's do it.
- [Woman 13] We drove four hours.
Thank you so much.
- [Man 15] Got a real
quick question here.
- [Gary] Invest in your business
- [Man 15] Right,
but when you were 20,--
- [Gary] Yes, yes.
- [Man 15] When
you were starting out,
you didn't have a
wife and three kids
that you had to take to swim.
- [Gary] You still have to--
- How do you break
up that time?
- You don't,
that's your reality.
- You just do it.
- Do you know what I mean?
Like I don't care
that I didn't have that.
I have it now,
how do I do it now?
Like you make choices,
I don't come on weekends
to anything, but I did today.
I made a choice, like...
You make choices.
- [Man 15] Alright.
- [Gary] You know what I mean?
- [Man 15] I do,
I do, it's just--
- [Gary] You can't want it
the way other people have it.
You wish you were 22 and had
unlimited, who gives a fuck?
You have your reality,
you take them to swimming
and then the nine
hours you have, you do it.
Like, it is what it is.
- [Man 15] Priorities.
- Everybody changes,
yeah exactly.
Like I passed on some of
the greatest opportunities
of my career because
my kid had a play.
Other times I said I'm
gonna go to this thing,
and my kid had a play.
You make choices,
and you live with them.
- [Man 15] Yeah, alright.
Alright, thanks man!
- [Gary] You got it.
- [Man 16] What I
want to do though
is eventually I want
to have my own company
but I have no
idea what I want to do,
or what industry
I want to go into.
- [Gary] Save money.
- [Man 16] Save money, yeah.
- [Gary] And learn.
Learn different things,
meet different people.
You'll stumble on
what you want to do.
("Lately" by Amon)
It's one by one,
that's how we got there.
We believed in
what I believe in,
which is there's
no silver bullet.
One restaurant at a time.
It's hard.
- [Man 17] It is hard.
- [Gary] But building big
businesses should be hard.
- [Man 17] I agree.
- [Gary] Like why
shouldn't it be hard?
Do you understand?
- [Man 17] Yes.
- That's what's so
interesting to me.
People are like "It's hard!"
It should be hard!
We spend so much time
on what we don't have
versus focusing on what we have
and so, I'm energetic because
I'm grateful and I'm happy
and when you're happy,
like, everything clicks.
And so I think I get my energy
from natural chemicals for sure.
But other than that I would say
gratitude is my
biggest driver for energy.
Not everybody needs to build
a trillion dollar business.
Like maybe you're at a
place where you're like
hmm it'd be cool to sell,
create some stability,
get some cash in, I'll
eat shit for a year or two
and stay at the
company that buys me.
I've got other dreams,
other ambitions,
other businesses
I want to build.
That's a sense of
getting that you're debating,
and I think that's cool.
I think when you
seek consolidation
there's two things.
One, when there's massive
consolidation there's
opportunity cause a lot of the
people that compete with you
are gonna get
eaten up and then suck
because they're
part of big things.
So this is your time to grow.
You might also be tired, bored,
or intrigued by something else,
so this may be the
time for you to sell.
- [Ratis] Hi, I'm Ratis.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Ratis] Good,
I have a question.
Do you think it's possible
to have a full time job
and still have a
successful business?
- [Gary] It's hard, but yes.
I think you can
start the foundation
for a successful business--
- [Ratis] But eventually to
grow you need to quit your job?
- [Gary] Yeah, you can't do it.
Like successful like how?
- [Ratis] So I've built
my jewelry business
for five years,
did that full time.
I'm a practicing
attorney though.
Went back to
practicing law, and now--
- [Gary] What I would do is
decide what you want to do.
Do you want to run
the jewelry business?
- [Ratis] Yes,
but I want more money.
- [Gary] Right so,
do the attorney thing,
save, live more humbly.
Like how much are these shoes?
- A lot of money.
- [Gary] Got it.
That's your only way.
I'm talking your actions.
So if you really want to do--
- [Ratis] I know, I make
good money but I want more.
- [Gary] I get it,
so if you want more
but you want to
do the jewelry thing,
you have to give up something.
- [Ratis] I want to
give up my legal career,
but not make less money.
- [Gary] I know
what you want to do.
So you have to
give up the fucking shit
you're buying between that.
I'm out.
On a serious note,
shit's good man.
Hustling, driving, reacting.
Living.
I appreciate you guys
being a part of this journey.
It's so crazy, huh?
("Lately" by Amon)